The final connection that I learned from
Justin Martyr.
The final connection.
And here he says the cross. Who was the
stone? Jesus, right? The stone.
I don't need to remind I showed you that
earlier.
First Corinthians 10:4, Acts 4:8-11.
Jesus is the stone, the rock.
I learned this from Justin Martyr.
And Jesus was crucified on a hill,
right? Hill?
On a hill? Golgotha?
Hill?
Okay.
Exodus 17:8-16.
Then Amalek came and fought against
Israel at Rephidim.
Rephidim.
The word Rephidim can also mean shades,
valley of the dead.
Shades, right? So Moses said to Joshua,
shades meaning souls, those who have
died.
Choose men for us.
Who's going to fight?
For us and go out fight against Amalek.
Tomorrow I'll take my stand at the top
of the hill with the staff of God in my
hand. Staff. What did Jesus carry to the
hill? His staff, the patibulum.
The staff.
Right?
And Joshua did as Moses told him to
fight against Amalek. Moses, Aaron, and
Hur. How many will be on the hill?
Three.
Went up to the top of the hill.
So it happened when Moses raised up his
hand
that Israel prevailed. Notice, when did
Joshua defeat their enemies? When Moses'
hands were stretched out.
Justin used this against Trypho.
Okay?
And when he let his left hand down, I'm
sorry, and when he let his hand down,
Amalek prevailed. So what happened?
Moses' hands were heavy, got tired. They
took a stone. He had to be seated on the
stone.
You must be planted on the stone. He sat
on it. Aaron and Hur supported his
hands. So that's proof his hands were
outstretched.
Aaron on one side, Hur on the other.
Three.
Stretched out like a cross.
As Joshua defeats them by the sign
of the cross, right?
Hand goes down, Joshua is not winning.
He could only win when his hand
stretched out. Three.
Father, Son, Holy Spirit working
together
through the death of Christ to bring
salvation to the world.
How do I know? Three work
in the salvation
of the world
by the cross of Christ. So I know.
And again,
three on the hill. Christ and two
criminals as a sign that he came to die
to save sinners.
Look how many worked with Christ.
Hebrews 9:14. How much more will the
blood of Christ want through the eternal
spirit to
Christ and his spirit work together to
offer Christ as an unblemished sacrifice
to God the Father.
And who was in Christ? God the Father.
John 10:37-38.
John 14:7-11. Cleanse your conscience
from dead works to serve the living God.
Mind blown, shocked, numbed. All right.
So the fact that they both had to stand
and hold his hands, he was in a crucifix
position. And the stone? Christ. He's
the stone.
And Aaron and Hur supported his hands,
one on one side, one on the other. Thus
his hands were steady until the sunset.
So Joshua overwhelmed Amalek and his
people to the edge of the sword.
Only when Moses' hands were stretched
out on a stone with Aaron and Hur.
Three. So that's how Jesus defeats our
enemies by his cross.
And who defeated them? Jesus.
Then I always said to Moses, write this
in a book and I'll get you an image of
it, a memorial and cite it in Joshua's
hearing,
that I utterly blot out the memory of
Amalek from under the heaven.
Moses built an altar, named it Yahweh is
my banner.
And he said, because he has sworn with a
hand
>> [clears throat]
>> upon the throne of Yah. Oh, the throne
of Yah.
Yahweh will have war against
Amalek from generation to generation.
Now let's look at the imagery.
And this I got from Joshua, from Justin
Martyr.
And we're done. We're done, folks.
Moses, Aaron, Hur
stretched out hands. I want to see the
imagery.
Amalek. Let's see the imagery.
There you go.
The imagery. You tell me it doesn't
resemble Christ's hands stretched out on
the cross?
See that?
Doesn't look like a cross?
The staff. You see the staff?
You're telling me that's another
coincidence?
That's another coincidence?
And I got this from Justin Martyr.
Christ [snorts] carried the patibulum.
John 19:17.
And he was on a hill, Golgotha.
Justin saw this.
It is the cross means savior of the
world.
So Jesus, there Jesus, Joshua defeated
them by the cross.
Moses on a stone, Christ is the stone.
Three working with Moses to stretch out
his hand, a very uncomfortable
position, signifying the work of
salvation was the work of the Trinity.
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. All three
working
through the physical body of Christ as
Christ died on the cross to save us.
And you're telling me your Bible's not
supernatural?
Beautiful, isn't it?
Look at this.
You see what he saw?
Because he was filled with the Holy
Spirit.
May the same Holy Spirit that fills him
fill us to love Jesus and die glorifying
Christ so we can rest forever.
Image after image, brethren.
Image after image.
Your Bible is all about Jesus.
It's all about Jesus. And what did our
Lord say here? Let me show you.
Here. Let's end it here.
And I'm going to send you to the debate
which is going to happen in 2 hours and
I'm going to take a rest.
I'm tired. Please, if you love me for
the sake of the Lord, pray for my
throat, my health. I'm losing weight,
lost close to 20. I got to lose 40 more.
Stay healthy and fit and holy. Pray
miraculous safety, security, protection,
my daughters, my angels.
Please pray for my support. I don't lose
support. Otherwise I won't be able to do
this. Stay steady.
Use it lawfully. Be a man of integrity.
Glorify Christ. Provide for them. Do the
work of ministry. PayPal, Patreon. I
don't lose support. Be a man of
integrity, holiness. God save me. This
young lady, do a miracle. Keep her pure
until marriage. Help me.
Die to sin, hate sin. Acknowledge my sin
and my weakness and not become something
I'm not. Get to church.
And we have to wait. If God wants her to
marry me, we got to wait. If not,
release her, help me break it up. But
nonetheless, let's end it.
You search the scriptures. John 5:39-40.
You search the scriptures
because you think that in them you have
eternal life.
It is these that bear witness about me.
You see that?
Every event, every person
is a picture of Christ. Not just
statements about someone in the future.
The sacraments were prefigured. Crossing
the Red Sea, baptism. The Jordan by
Joshua being baptized into Christ. Why
that second one? To show you your
baptism in Moses can't save you. You
must be saved and baptized into Jesus to
enter the promised land.
The manna, your Eucharist, which stops
when you enter heaven. They enter
earthly Canaan, celebrate the Passover.
When our Lord comes down and brings
heavenly Canaan Jerusalem to the earth,
celebrate the Passover. All about Jesus.
All about Jesus. King Deplorable, Tanya
Sark.
They all bear witness to me. You're
unwilling to come to me so that you may
have life.
>> [snorts]
>> John 5:45-47.
Do not think that I'll accuse you to the
Father. The one who accuses you is Moses
in whom you have set your hope. For you
believe Moses, you would have believed
me. He wrote about me. You better
believe he did. From him on a stone,
holding a staff, hands stretched out
form of the cross, Aaron and her holding
it up, from changing Hosea to Joshua.
But if you not believe his writings, how
will you believe my words?
It's all about Jesus.
Remember, Christ has been raised. He's
alive. He is reality. He's the truth. He
is life
with the Father and the Spirit, the one
God, Father, Spirit. He's God in the
flesh. The saints are alive.
The Holy Mother is alive. Justin Martyr
is alive. They're alive cuz he's not
dead.
And they pray for us cuz they love us.
May the Queen of Heaven, all the saints,
Saint Justin, Saint Jerome,
all of them pray for us. Saint Paul,
Saint Peter, all of them pray for us.
The blood of Christ wash your loved
ones, my daughters, and all of us in the
spirit seal them and fill them on us to
love our Father,
to love our God and savior Lord Jesus
Christ, our Joshua, and love you Holy
Spirit.
>> [clears throat]
>> Heal us, save us, protect us.
Save us from dogs and wolves. Expose
them.
And do not allow us to fall into
scandal. Kyrie eleison. Kyrie eleison.
Kyrie eleison. Let me end it one more
time
with the Divine Mercy
prayer. Let me just get there.
Let me see there.
Okay.
Can I find it? Here it goes.
Let me read this.
You expired, Jesus,
but the source of life gushed forth for
souls,
and the
ocean of mercy
opened up for the whole world.
For the sake of his sorrowful passion,
have mercy on us and on the whole world.
Kyrie eleison. Kyrie eleison. Kyrie
eleison.
Name of the Father, and of the Son, of
the Holy Spirit. Blessed God, three in
one, Jesus name, Maranatha.
See you soon.